well guys this is it we are finally at
the last collaboration video between the
schmoes doe and myself today we're going
to be talking about Superman
doomsday the DC animated original film
and before I get into my review I will
let you guys enjoy the schmoes review of
Superman doomsday hello Chris thanks for
having us back on the show and I'll tell
you what we've had a lot of fun
reviewing all these old Superman films
and unfortunately they're only 5 really
theatrical ones released and then we
started thinking about what are we going
to do next well we also needed something
to get the taste out of our mouths from
Superman 3 & 4 in some extensive
remember terms the funny thing is about
doomsday is the cartoon yeah there are
tons of cartoons so I think that are
better than this one but the reason that
I think that we're doing is because you
it's the only time you actually really
get to see this legendary character that
in the comics killed yes Superman he
croaks I mean look I when I was a kid I
remember the comic book series coming
out and I owned it because I mean there
is no cooler cover ever than just the
black with the S logo dripping blood the
death of Superman is just so cool from a
you know really sick standpoint it's a
very interesting storyline doomsday ends
up killing them so we get to see those
battles go down and see if Superman can
actually literally come back from the
dead the first half of this movie is
pretty cool because you get the you get
that the element that you were just
talking about I'm watching how this
beast this crazy yes it's really a super
soldier that he comes back in on the
Friday now because Lex Corp is is doing
something and there's a spaceship and
then doomsday emerges from the spaceship
he kills all Alexis people right there
and then he says look he goes to the
tropics he goes on a murderous rampage
and Superman needs to fly in to stop and
he and Lois Lane to work on the
relationship at the fortress of solitude
Superman comes in they have this great
battle and it doesn't go Supes way right
for a little bit and then you know
always dead he's dead he's dead then he
comes back and he's he may be a little
evil or some dude he comes back and he
he's victorious but I just in the second
half of the movie kind of fell flat for
me because it just it you lost it oh
here's this that big battle and then
there's just a lot of kind of diatribes
here and there and it's just kind of I
mean without doomsday in the second half
of the movie I mean because yeah
also got a little a little campy or mean
again it's look we're reviewing a
cartoon and I really have a problem tan
cartoony seriously I did like a Batman
mask of the phantasm
and I thought this was really cable and
had a very serious tone the damn thing
is rated pg-13 yeah
and if it doesn't get a little simile of
Superman's clone is I don't want some of
it you can't tell if if it sued the Lois
and they're not sure that this is real
Superman ends up not being because Lex
Luthor has the real Superman's body and
he's keeping it like Jabba the Hutt
keeps han Solo frozen in carbonite
it's just there for his amusement um
yeah I think that was it I do I love
cartoons I think I can take it take them
pretty seriously when they're darker and
tone I used to love the old spawn series
and I thought this movie this movie was
getting dark and then it just I don't
know just the storyline just kind of
fell a little flat like I said so
overall I think there are tons better
animations that I'd like to see that
I've heard about I'd like to hear what
you guys think about it too so I want to
read in the comments as well what to
suggest the vocal talent was top-notch
so because Adam Baldwin really pulled
off Superman vibe and James Marsters as
Lex Luthor on Anne Heche as Lois Lane is
fine it's a it's funny because it's like
if you think you're gonna have problems
now talking just the only time you guys
can hook up to the fortress of solitude
quickly find out who and hash is really
attracted to oh okay so overall this
movie I'm gonna gum steal your skill
here I'm gonna go to point eight out of
five shows oh come on I'm gonna get it
fresh I think it's like three two
corridor out of vibe Mo's I could
probably go three and a half and still
have um credibility in life but you know
it's it's it's a nice Superman story I
like that it wasn't too long it's a
cartoon not even eighty minutes I don't
think so I think it's worth checking out
as you're leading up to the excitement
building around Man of Steel so it
better that then Superman three or four
well speaking of which Chris was a lot
of fun doing these collaborations with
you and I think that again I think your
review of Man of Steel is coming up
pretty soon as is ours so make sure you
check out his review our review and
thank you so much and we'll look forward
to doing other ones with you very soon
absolutely man big superhero franchises
that's why you call the schmoes that's
why you call Stockman Chris back to you
buddy nice toss
Superman doomsday is based off of one of
the most famous comic book arcs I
remember in the mid-90s when this was
coming out I would go to my local comics
store it's a place called JC
comics I love that place and I remember
hearing about that story and thinking
would supermoon is dead because I was
like 10 years old in the mid 90s so I
didn't know what was going on
and it scared me I saw the blood-red
superman emblem and I was like no but
now that I'm an adult and understand
what's going on it is one of my favorite
comic book stories I have it right there
the full arc and that's why I was
looking forward to seeing Superman
doomsday because it was something that I
was like wow that's a lot of really good
source material if there's a lot of
really good drama in there it's a good
comic book story it's one of the coolest
Superman stories and that's why I was
very disappointed with this animated
version they really did no justice to
the comic really I mean it doesn't
follow the storyline even remotely I
mean I guess the closest thing is that
Superman and doomsday do fight that
Superman does fall by Doomsday's hand
and that later in the film Superman
comes back and has like a black suit on
other than that there really isn't that
much else in the comics that is in this
film it's all changed the Justice League
has been removed now Lex Luthor
discovers doomsday to get Lex Luthor in
there somehow and I really feel like the
raw emotion has just been stripped right
out of that story for this movie that
being said it's not a terrible animated
film it'll keep your attention I would
say for its short run time but it just
doesn't have what that are provided and
for serious fans of the comics this is a
really big disappointment and all the
stuff that it added just felt like
baggage I mean there was such a cool
story there can you imagine if they had
included all of the various elements of
the various Superman that were in that
comic not just the the clones can you
imagine how cool it would have been if
they included the members of the Justice
League they were actually in that comic
there was just so much there in that
original story that was just not
included that could have been so much
better for this movie but they decided
to go in like the cliched safe routes
like will bring Lex Luthor in there have
Lex Luthor be the overseer of all this
stuff and add all these things that just
didn't need to be there so it made the
movie kind of uninteresting for me and I
didn't really enjoy that much I thought
that it could have been a lot better
that being said the animation is pretty
good it is entertaining for what it is I
wasn't bored by it but it just could
have been a lot more because of the
source material provided a lot more that
they didn't really go into so I'm going
to give Superman doomsday a see there
are
some other better Superman animated
films up there I would say the world's
finest the Batman Superman movie that's
one you should check out that one's
pretty good I like that one a lot
low guys my Man of Steel review will be
up late Tuesday night I'm extremely
excited to bring you guys that review
and also I just want to say thanks very
much Mo's it's been nice doing these
collaboration videos with you we did
Batman in the past now we've covered
Superman we've officially collaborated
on the two most popular DC heroes and
it's been great doing this with you guys
I really appreciate the collab it was a
lot of fun and as always guys if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck menage